bitcoin ripping through 50 000
do you hear it do you hear it 50k
bitcoin
a couple of weeks ago about two three
weeks ago people were yelling it was
going to 20 000. they were saying that
it was gonna be in a bear market it was
over michael bury the famous big short
guy was screaming and yelling about
heads and shoulders and whatever other
triangles he draws on charts
because technical analysis is just
astrology for grown men
50 000 bitcoin as we continue to say be
responsible don't short bitcoin this
thing will rip in your face
and take your soul and that's what it's
been doing now if we actually look at
the chart itself we can see that there
are some very interesting market
dynamics that are playing out why i
think bitcoin is going to go much much
higher throughout the rest of this year
so first let's look at the all-time
bitcoin chart you can see that bitcoin
basically went from nothing to today at
over 50
and just when you start to think that it
would had peaked and it was going to
fall aggressively it has come roaring
back so this is the uh all-time chart
for bitcoin if you then look and see the
last 90 days you can see that there is
a complete growth it was under 40 000.
90 days ago today it's crossed over 50
000 we continue to see healthy growth
over that 90 day period
on top of that this is the bitcoin price
but we have the bitcoin realized
price what that means is the actual
dollars that are equal to the number of
bitcoin when it last moved so if i
bought bitcoin at let's say 20 000
that's the last time those coins moved
that would be twenty thousand dollars
towards the realized cap and so what you
see is we have hit an all-time high in
the bitcoin realized capped that is very
very bullish for the long term and so
our favorite young wizard will clemente
tweeted over the weekend he said 83
of bitcoin supply hasn't moved in at
least three months and 70 percent hasn't
moved in at least six months
so again what we are seeing is we are
seeing the long-term strong hands of
bitcoin they've been buying up as much
bitcoin as they could at these
discounted prices over the last couple
of months and they are holding and they
are not going to sell and it is the
setup for a massive supply squeeze we've
seen from 30 to 50 000 in a very short
period of time my guess is that we will
definitely hit a hundred thousand
dollars before the end of the year as
i've been saying since 2019 but on top
of that we will likely blow through that
and see a much much higher price point
how high can we go i don't know but i
don't think 100k will be the top this
year again past performance does not
equal future performance and i don't
know the future any better than anybody
else but from a probabilistic standpoint
i like our chances another interesting
chart around bitcoin is the fact that
the hash rate once china banned mining
in certain jurisdictions within their
borders we saw a hash rate fall off a
cliff it then bottomed in july and now
has come roaring back bitcoin's hash
rate today is about where we were in
november of 2020. we already have gotten
back to november 2020 levels in hash
rate my guess is that we will continue
to see this grow at a very fast rate
through the rest of this year and likely
hit a bitcoin hash rate all-time high
before the year is over so when you
start to look at all of the data whether
it is the price chart the realized uh
cap chart if it is the long-term holders
if it is the strong hands if it's hash
rate if it's even transaction history
and volume you can see that bitcoin
looks very very healthy on the
fundamentals when you add in the fact
that 70 of bitcoin has not moved in the
last six months and if you account for
lost coins it's actually over 80 percent
of bitcoin has not moved in the last six
months it tells you that the strong
hands will continue to be strong and as
increased demand comes into the market
my guess is that bitcoin will go much
higher john and joe odds that you guys
disagree that bitcoin's going much
higher this year zero zero zero yeah
like not like not even a chance that we
see a lower bitcoin price people there's
always chance like i don't think anyone
expected what happened in china to
happen right so there's always outside
things like that that could probably
impact the price uh but when you look at
the fundamentals everything you just
mentioned it's clear that uh the demand
is strong and as long as those coins are
are continuously held by strong hand
seventy 70 80 of the market is not going
to move you can quickly see the price
appreciate as more demand comes in the
market
one of the things that i think is
drastically underpriced or mispriced in
the market is things like the lightning
network right we've shown the chart last
week where basically there's parabolic
growth in the number of public nodes in
the lightning network and i think the
more that we see all these underlying
fundamentals continuing to move up and
to the right what it shows is a high
propensity for increase of demand right
remember july was the most
growth the fastest acceleration of users
onboarding onto the bitcoin blockchain
in history 1.2 million people of new
demand coming in in july
if that continues and you have those
strong hands what do you get you get
price appreciation supply is constricted
demand increases of course if you're a
believer of supply demand economics the
price has to go up to accommodate
everyone my guess is that a lot of
corporations a lot of financial
institutions they were getting excited
at the beginning of this year when
bitcoin went from 10 to 30 000. they
went from 30 to 64 000. they got
overheated they got nervous when we went
from 64 down to 30 000 but now that
we've crept back up to 50 000 there's a
psychological barrier that gets broken
and my guess is we're going to see a lot
of corporations a lot of financial
institutions start to announce their
participation in the industry in a
variety of different ways as we see that
occurring i think it will only lead to
more and more demand and likely towards
the end of the year we will get a
massive blow off top again 2017 bitcoin
went from 10 000 to 20 000 in 18 days or
so i don't know what the prices are
gonna be but there will be some massive
acceleration blow off top and then we'll
kind of get a cooling off again and so
what people have to remember is the
fundamentals are very different than the
public narrative or the sentiment on
twitter if you look at the underlying
fundamentals and you believe that the
data is the data what i think about it
what joe or john thinks about bitcoin
does not matter the data is the data it
is very very bullish right john yeah
does it worry you that so many whales
are accumulating so much bitcoin right
so
the problem with a lot of the new coins
that people ran into were basically like
a rug pull in the sense of the creator
would have so much power and so many
coins that when he decided to sell his
coins it dropped the price right so
you've seen
whales by 13 000 30 000 different
like individual bitcoins in a single day
or a single week like does that work you
know at all no if you think of michael
saylor michael saylor owns a hundred and
five thousand bitcoin through micro
strategy right 155 numbers
well rookie numbers yeah sure
105 000 bitcoin and that's not even 0.5
of the bitcoin
right so he didn't even own one percent
he owns half a percent a little less
than half a percent of bitcoin and he
owns 105 000 so somebody who comes in
and buys 13 20 50 000 bitcoin they
obviously own even less than he does and
so i think that while the numbers seem
big because we think of oh my god
somebody bought hundreds of millions or
bought a billion dollars worth of
bitcoin it's still a really small number
because you have to remember bitcoin's a
950 billion dollar asset right now
trillionaire energy and so it's likely
to go back up over a trillion by the end
of this year right and go much much
higher and so if all of a sudden we
start getting into bitcoin as a two
three four trillion dollar asset again i
don't know where it's going but let's
just say it goes up much more than a
trillion somebody comes in even if they
bought 500 million dollars worth of
bitcoin or a billion or even if they
bought 10 billion dollars of bitcoin a
trillion plus dollar asset it's such a
small percentage compared to the the
overall size of the market and i'm
assuming that that means that just one
seller couldn't move the market like
that right so unless it
unless it starts a panic of selling then
one seller can't really affect the
market and
i mean listen if you're selling bitcoin
right now it's just getting eaten up
right we saw to go from 64 000 to 30 000
you had to have a lot of selling right
the price went down more than 50 so
people were obviously selling in the
market the reason why price goes down is
because there's more sellers than buyers
right the reason why price goes up is
because there's more buyers than sellers
and so when you look at that selling
it's not so much was there more selling
or less selling it's who was selling and
bitcoin provides with that public ledger
the first time where we can really see
with granular detail who is selling how
long have they held the bitcoin where
did they buy the bitcoin in terms of
price point and who are they selling to
what is the historical um kind of
behavior of those people buying all of
this is on the blockchain with the
on-chain metrics and so what we talked
about for i mean i felt like a broken
record for weeks if not months on this
show and on the podcast we talked about
over and over and over again the
short-term
weak hands the people who are new to the
market they were the ones selling they
were dumping bitcoin they were so scared
they just had the weak hands the lettuce
hands they were just selling all the
bitcoin and the people sitting on the
other side were the smart money the
strong hands the people have been around
for a long time and so what you
ultimately got was you got a bunch of
people who were buying bitcoin i bought
a ton of bitcoin around 30 000 right it
was discounted bitcoin compared to what
the underlying fundamentals said and so
the more that you saw the price going
down the more that people who have been
around for a long time said oh wait a
second there's a mispricing in the
market there's a separation between what
the on chain metrics say and what we're
seeing with the actual price behavior
this is a good opportunity now they
could be wrong right but so far in the
short stan um kind of perspective a
couple of weeks bitcoin from 30 000 back
to 50 000
looks like all those people were right
yeah and i think the other thing to add
is that uh when you look at the
distribution of kind of where we're
seeing that demand from so if you think
about uh we're seeing in in 2017 we're
only seeing 16 percent of the google
search term of the trends that we saw in
2017. so from an interest perspective on
a retail basis it's much much much lower
this time than it was before even when
we hit an all-time high earlier this
year at 60 000 we were only seeing 50 of
the same interest in google so we've
seen the price appreciate two and a half
to three times uh more than it had of
the previous all-time high at this point
this year and we're seeing 50 percent
less demand from a retail perspective
within google search trends so if you
look at it from an institutional basis
obviously those institutions are playing
the fundamentals on chain tell you one
thing but you can also look at kind of
uh monitors like this that say hey look
there's probably a lot more retail
interest to come here and as we get to
80 90 100k that's when you start to see
all those people flood in and you
eventually get that blow off top oh
there's going to be the great fomo of
2021 is gonna happen later this year and
there's a bunch of people if you on the
street right now and you ask people how
much is bitcoin worth the average person
will have no clue there are people who
still think bitcoin is five thousand
dollars from the bear market of 2018
into 2019. there's people who thought
that oh it rained up a lot earlier this
year and then it crashed and it's over
and they might think that bitcoin still
thirty thousand dollars right if people
don't pay attention to this all day then
they have no clue about those intricate
price movements and so what ends up
happening is you get a bunch of uh kind
of new media attention a whole nother
media run right i went on cnbc this
morning what do you want to talk about
they want to rob bitcoin right why do
they want to talk about bitcoin price is
moving up all of a sudden now it's back
in the conversation last couple of weeks
when a lot of people want to talk about
bitcoin because the price was down and
so although price ultimately won't
matter for bitcoin in terms of the us
dollar exchange price it is important
now because price ends up being a great
indicator for uh the amount of attention
it drives that attention leads to
marketing the marketing leads to user
acquisition the user acquisition leads
to more demand more demand leads to
higher price it's a whole fulfilling uh
kind of cycle but it ultimately is
driven by the fact that 80 of bitcoin
that is known not to be lost
and is in circulation
has not moved in six months think about
the last six months we're now in month
eight of the year right we're in august
that means that bitcoin went from about
30 000 to 60 back to 30 now it's at 50.
think about that volatility for a second
it doubled it got cut by more than 50
and then it went back up again and now
it's at uh uh 50 000
and still
80
of known non-lost coins have not moved
in six months those people are not
selling you literally cannot shake them
out of bitcoin and so when you have that
level of kind of strong hands what you
ultimately get is uh one increased
demand is going to shoot price up
aggressively and then two is we're also
likely to see there is a price point
where some of those people will sell
right it's what happened back if you go
back to q4 in november and december
institutions showed up and said joe and
john i want your bitcoin i'll pay you
ten thousand dollars and bitcoiner said
no then they said i'll give you 12 15 18
20 000 bitcoiner said no then we saw 22
25 28 30 000
no and eventually what started to happen
was once we got over thirty thousand
dollars we started to see people selling
into the market so there was a price
that people were willing to sell at it
just was much higher than where it
started at thirty thousand dollars or
i'm sorry ten thousand dollars so when
we see these high levels of coins that
haven't moved in a long time it usually
is then followed by hundreds of percent
of appreciation and so if we saw you
know a hundred plus thousand dollars by
the end of the year i don't think anyone
here would be surprised hey guys thanks
so much for watching that clip of the
best business show make sure you like
and subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it
you